[Music]
so hello everyone welcome back to my
podcast my name is Zer Mish and I am so
excited to talk about this podcast
tonight and we're going to talk about
learning a second language a journey of
cultural
enrichment so before we start uh we
should know that my topic is separating
six part including introduction the
significance of learning a second
language cognitive benefits of language
learning C uh cultural
enrichment the Journey of language
learning and in the end but not least
conclusion so why we don't start
introduction language is the most
fundamental tool of human
communication serving as a brid between
cultures ideas and people while many
people around the world grow up
bilingual or multi
lingual they are countless other who
embark on the Journey of learning a
second language later in their
life so this is easy explores the
significance of learning second language
and the cognitive benefits it
offers and the cultur cultural
enrichment it brings to one's
life then we have the signification of
learning a second language learning a
second language is a transformative
experience that opens that opens door to
new worlds both um in today's
interconnected word it has became
increasingly important it allows
individuals to connect with a broader
range of people both personality and
professionality R the ability to
communicate in more than one language is
available
skill in changing job Pro uh prospects
and frustrating gross cultural
understanding it it also can be an act
of personal Improvement providing
individuals with the tools to navigate
an increasingly globalized Society
then we have cognitive benefits of
language learning the cognitive benefits
of learning is second language or
numerals research has constantly show
that bilingual individuals tend to have
enhanced cognitive abilities compared to
monolinguals learning a second language
exes the brain improving memory problem
solving skills and multi- asking
abilities it can also delay the unset of
cognitive uh decline in older age so
what are you waiting for go learn second
language moreover language learning is
an exercise in PN recognition and C
creativity sorry as lers grasp the
interior case of grammar and
vocabulary this cognitive stimulation
can lead to improve General int
intellectual
abilities I hope you don't get bored
until there then we have cultural
enrichment behind the particle Advantage
learning a second language offers
profound cultural culture enrichment
language is a carer of culture and by
learning a new language one gains
insight into the Customs traditions and
perspective of a particular
Community language is a window into the
way people
think perceive the world and express and
express s their
emotions it also it allow individuals to
connect on a deeper level with speakers
of the language uh frustrating empathy
and
understanding the study of new language
often involves delving into lures art
music and history from the cultures
where language is spoken further uh
broading on her Horizons then guys we
have the Journey of language
learning learning a second language is
not with uh with a challenge we know
that it demands dedication patience and
perseverance the process can be
frustrating at times as leers graple
with unfamiliar songs structures and
vocabulary like me right
now yet the journey is itself available
available experience it teach us relance
and the importance of uh continuous
learning offering a table sense of
achievement when Mill stones are
reached then in the end we have
conclusion uh in a world that is
becoming increasingly
interconnected the significance of
learning a second language cannot be
overstated if offers part iCal benefits
such improve job prospects and cognitive
abilities but more importantly it en
reach um one's life
culturally so languages get away to
understanding and connecting with
different cultures Foster rating
empathy and creating a more inclusive
world as individuals embark on the
Journey of learning a second language
they not only me a new form of explosion
but also embark on a journey of
self-discovery and Global
understanding so in the end uh I want to
add something by
myself we know that most famous and talk
language in world is
English then in second is Mandarian I
think it's China I think there Asian
countries including there in the third
we have the Hindi in the fourth we have
Spanish in the fifth we have French in
the sixth we have modern
Arabic in the seventh we have Russian
and in the eighth the last but not least
we have
Portuguese let's talk a little about our
country Albanian
language we know that Albanian language
is not that famous and we know that is
one of the hardest Lang language in the
world but as albanians we should be
proud of something
because we should know that is one of
the first language in a
world so we should know that if we know
a second language in Kosovo is a better
life there I I think is a key of success
uh because we get a better life we get a
better job we get a better payment
everything is fine if you know a second
language so what are we waiting for go
in course read books watch films that
not that are not
alinan so guys this was all thank you
for your time I hope you don't get
bored uh I was
missish I hope you get something new
thank you for your
time